on any given page like this one you can
open the chrome developer tools by
clicking on the shortcut listed in tools
developer tools as you can see chrome
dev tools provides a series of tabs that
allow you to debug and inspect your web
apps for example you can select any
element on the page by right-clicking
the element and selecting inspect
element or as I'll do here you can click
on the magnifying glass and hover over
the area that you would like to inspect
let's take a look at the unordered list
of floor selectors let's change the text
in one of the floor selectors we can do
that by simply expanding the element
that contains it and an editing is live
on the page you can also make live edits
to the CSS let's take a look at changing
the selected floor class here I can set
the background color to whatever I want
for example blanched almond because who
doesn't like blanched almonds because
the background color is now pretty light
we may also want to change the text
color chrome dev tools provides a handy
color picker for death we can pick any
color we want
shift clicking the color picker allows
you to cycle through two different color
schemes RGB HSL and so on if we scroll a
little bit further to our floor selector
class we can play around with the
different settings there you can use the
scroll wheel to cycle through the
different sizes and we can set the
border width in a similar fashion as you
can see chrome dev tools provides with
rich functionality to edit and inspect
your pages and that was just one tab
we'll be diving deeper into the network
timeline and profiles tabs with Colt
McAnlis
in the performance lesson and we'll
cover the resources tab in more detail
in the lesson about offline and storage